c'est une première les restos du coeur
organisent leurs premières portes
ouvertes samedi 25 juin dans toute la
france et les yvelines participent que
ce soit pour récolter des informations
sur l'aide alimentaire ou bien pour
s'engager au sein de l'association les
bénévoles seront là pour répondre à
toutes les questions c'est vraiment une
première problème pour les restos du
coeur jeudi d'une façon générale donc
dans toute la france
pourquoi pourquoi la journée portes
ouvertes c'est que jusqu'à ce jour les
réseaux sont surtout connus
en termes de communication extérieure
surtout par le concert des et
la collecte nationale donc ces deux
temps forts qui ont qui avait lieu en
début d'année et là l'idée de
l'association nationale c'est de
relancer un peu l'image des restos alors
que la précarité s'aggrave et que les
prix augmentent ces journées portes
ouvertes sont l'occasion pour les restos
du coeur d'aller à la rencontre de ceux
qui n'osent pas pousser les portes des
centres d'accueil
au total une quinzaine de sites seront
ouverts le matin ou l'après midi dont le
chantier d'insertion aux
clayes-sous-bois le premier travail
c'est la socialisation socialisation et
que lorsqu'on a levé tous ces obstacles
tous ces blocages on peut ensuite aller
vers la recherche d'emploi donc il ya
des bénévoles pour chaque bénéficiaire
il ya un bénévole qui l'accompagnent
dans sa recherche d'emploi dans
l'élaboration de son projet
professionnel souvent méconnus du public
l'association ne se charge pas seulement
de faire de l'aide alimentaire elle
s'engage également dans l'accompagnement
au numérique juridique ou même dans
l'aide au logement cette journée est
ouverte à tous